And today what we find in the western
world when people who mainly talk about
feminism they have that little bit of
aura that you know women are superior.
So in this context I'm not a feminist
but truly if you go by the definition
what it literally means it means that
men and women have equal rights.
So therefore I call feminism as a
misnomer.
If I go out and say that Zak Nik is a
feminist, people will think okay he's
trying to say that women are more
superior than men.
If you go to AI, artificial intelligence
and let's ask artificial intelligence
what is feminism? So a I will tell you
that feminism
is a group of political and social
movements
to acquire
equal rights amongst both the genders.
Political and social movements
in order to acquire equal rights amongst
both gender which have no problem.
But today the western talk of women's
liberalization. Women's liberalization
is another word for feminism. It's a
coined word. Women's liberalization.
The western talk of women's liberization
is nothing but a disguised form of
exploitation of a body.
Degradation of honor and deprivation of
a soul. The western society claiming to
uplift the woman have actually degraded
the woman to a status of concubine,
mistresses and society butterflies
and society butterflies which are mere
tools in the hands of pleasure seekers
and sex marketeers which are hidden
behind the colorful screen of art and
culture. In the name of women's
liberalization,
the western society is degrading our
mothers, our daughters, our wives
to a status of concubine.
Society butterflies
which are mere tools in the hands of sex
marketeers and pleasure seekers hidden
behind the colorful
screen of art and culture in the name of
art and culture they are degrading. So
such type
of
western talk of women's civilization I
do not believe.
I do not care what
I do not care about the modern ideas.
The conclusions and categorical remarks
made by scientists and unexperienced
armchair experts
as how a life should be led by a woman.
I'm going to base my conclusion
on facts
which can be proved by experience.
For experience and holistic facts are
the sure test between the truth of gold
and the glitter of theory.
We have to check our minds otherwise our
minds will go astray.
There was a time when great minds of the
old times they thought the world was
flat.
And if you find
in the media
there is virilent propaganda regarding
Islam.
The international media is bombarding
misconceptions regarding Islam. And
there was a time before 9/11,
the maximum target regarding Islam was
on the topic of women, women's rights.
So most of the misconceptions before
9/11 were regarding women.
Why does Islam subjugate the woman by
speaking by keeping her behind the veil?
Why does Islam give permission for a man
to have more than one wife? Why do women
at half as compared to that of the men?
And so on and so forth. After 9/11, the
top of the charts changed. It became
jihad. Muslims are fundamentalists.
Muslims are terrorists. Muslims are
extremists. Islam was paired with a
sword.
So media is a powerful tool.